[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain the third and fourth episodes
of the south korean survival drama squid
game called the man with the umbrella
and stick to the team
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
in the previous episode all the main
characters from the show got into vans
to go back to the facility and gamble
their lives for money the police officer
june ho follows giun's van still looking
for his brother the van stops in a
harbor where several other vans just
like it are being loaded onto a ferry
june ho latches onto the bottom of gi
yoon's van and boards the ship as well
after some time the staff in red suits
start inspecting the players by scanning
their ears indicating the players have
been inserted with some device june ho
gets inside a van and knocks out the
staff that tries to inspect him he
changes into the man's clothes and mask
after the others leave he puts his id
into the man's pocket and throws him
into the sea one of the staff finds june
ho and asks what he is doing the man is
june host superior which makes him
realize that the shapes on their masks
indicate their positions he gets out of
this situation by saying that he is
seasick the ship stops at the island and
all the contestants are taken into a
hall while they are still unconscious
their clothes are changed and their
belongings are seized saibyak who is
still conscious manages to sneak in a
pocketknife the players wake up in the
hall again gi yoon reunites with the old
man inaum
seng wu and ali join the two as well
they decide to form a team so it will be
easier to win from the next round
similarly the gangster djoksu is also
forming his own team and asks sai biak
to join him she despises the man and
refuses to be on his team their
conversation is interrupted by menyo the
woman who begged the staff to let her go
when they were here previously she tries
to seduce yaksu to be on his team but he
insults her and leaves later the staff
is told to head back to their rooms
because their work for the day is done
june ho who has managed not to be caught
yet goes to his assigned room and sees
it as a surveillance camera at night
migno creates a fuss about wanting to
pee and bangs on the door for the guards
to let her out they allow her to go and
sybioc takes the opportunity to go out
as well it turns out migno has hidden a
packet full of cigarettes inside her
underwear that she then starts to smoke
saibiak gets inside minio's stall and
opens the vent on the ceiling with her
knife she goes in to inspect the
facility and ends up above the kitchen's
vent in the kitchen a large amount of
sugar is being melted sybioc quickly
returns back before the guards can catch
her she tells migno what she saw but
they dismiss it as unimportant
information the following day the
players are woken up and given bread and
some milk as breakfast gi yoon and the
team enjoy it together while talking
they're starting to bond especially enom
and giun who talk about their old days
with each other ali is kind to all of
them while sang wu seems to be void of
emotions as they talk an announcement
tells them it is time for the next game
on their way outside sang wu asks sybiak
what she saw yesterday it turns out that
he had heard her and migno talking last
night saibiak tells him that the staff
was melting sugar when they reach
outside sangwoo sees several shapes
drawn on the wall and realizes they are
playing an old korean game where they
have to break a sugar honeycomb snack
into a specific shape however he doesn't
tell his teammates and chooses the
easiest shape for himself gi yoon
chooses the shape of an umbrella which
is the hardest one but sang wu still
doesn't warn him they are given the
honeycomb and gi yoon realizes he is in
trouble there is no way he can crack the
shape of an umbrella perfectly sang wu
and sybiak get a triangle ali gets a
circle while inaum dyoksu and minyo get
a star the game starts and seng wu and
sybiak easily break their shapes ali
gets done soon as well migno on the
other hand hides under a slide and uses
a lighter to melt the sugar easily gi
yoon and enon struggle the most soon the
staff starts killing people who break
their shapes sang woo saibiak and ali
get done in no time nobody notices minio
cheating and she succeeds as well after
passing she throws the lighter towards
dioxu to help him even though he
insulted her earlier she desperately
wants to be in his team for the future
gi yoon realizes that if he licks the
honeycomb it will get thinner making it
easier to break into shapes people
around him follow his strategy including
enom at the last moment he manages to
get the shape of the umbrella out and
passes the round enom does the same and
succeeds as well however the ones who
failed are killed brutally the overseer
of the games watches everyone through a
monitor june ho is also in the field and
is horrified to see the real truth of
the game a superior with a square on his
mask asks him to do his duties of
picking up the bodies and meet him later
one of the players who failed refuses to
die and holds a staff member hostage he
makes the man take his mask off and sees
that the guy is just a kid filled with
guilt the player shoots himself and dies
the overseer approaches the staff who
has just been exposed and shoots him
dead claiming that no one's face should
be seen junhoe cleans the dead bodies
and finds the dead staff's mask who
happens to be the superior who called
him earlier he exchanges his mask with
the staff member's circle mask to
disguise himself as a higher ranking
staff member after the game the players
are brought back to their room however
the staff take player number 111 with
them it is revealed that some of the
staff are secretly harvesting the
player's organs to sell them number 111
is a surgeon who is helping them in
return they tell the man what each game
is going to be so he would pass them all
and they can continue their secret
mission meanwhile dioxu takes menyo to
his team for helping him earlier out of
the 187 players who participated 79 were
killed the following morning they are
given breakfast of an egg and a cold
drink dioxou complains about it not
being enough he and his team get into
the line twice to get more food because
of this a few people who were at the end
did not get any a woman reveals that she
saw the group take the food twice this
enrages a man who didn't get his food he
yells at yaksu to give him his share
back and tries to snatch the cold drink
from him an angered dyoksu hits him and
the two get into a fight dioksu beats
the man repeatedly to the point that he
lies limp on the ground when everything
goes silent senwoo comes to check on the
man only to find he is dead giun asks
the staff to do something and even looks
at the surveillance camera to ask the
overseer however the staff do not
intervene whatsoever and announce that
player number 271 is eliminated everyone
realizes that killing each other is fair
in this game this gives deoxy's group an
idea they can just kill everyone and win
the money for themselves
some staff members arrive with a coffin
and take the dead body away meanwhile
the doctor is still harvesting the
organs after he is done the staff ask
him to stick to the strongest team they
reveal that the management deliberately
supplied less food for breakfast because
they want the players to go wild and do
anything they can for the money even
kill each other at last they tell him
about the next game and make him leave
back in the hall everyone is scared for
their lives gi yoon and the team decide
to stay awake all night to be safe
seeing saibiak alone gi yoon invites her
to their group but she doesn't trust
them when the doctor returns to the hall
he looks around for the strongest team
taking the staff's advice he approaches
dioxu's team and asks them to take him
in deoxy makes fun of him at first but
accepts once he secretly tells him what
game will be played the following day
the staff is put on high alert for the
special game referring to the fight that
will occur when the lights go out as
soon as the lights are off the aksu's
team gets up and starts attacking people
dioxu makes the first kill and the
screams wake everyone up the overseer
watches everyone through the
surveillance camera's night vision he
orders one staff member to flicker the
lights in the room so the killings are
seen more clearly soon the bunk beds
start falling and the place turns into a
bloodbath dioxu attacks sybiak and is
about to strangle her to death but she
is saved when another guy attacks him gi
yoon's group meets each other amidst the
chaos but the old man enom is nowhere to
be seen sybiak joins giun's team for her
safety but the group is attacked by
dioxi's group again as they fight they
hear enom asking everyone to stop from
the highest bed the overseer sees this
and turns the lights on the staff walk
into the place covered in blood and dead
bodies they scan the dead bodies and an
announcement is made saying that 27 of
them have been eliminated the dead
bodies are taken out and burned in the
furnace after everything calms down giun
and the group gather and introduce
themselves to each other as they have
been calling each other by numbers until
now enam seems to be shaken up by the
incident and forgets his own name gi
yoon assures him he will be fine once he
takes rest meanwhile the doctor dresses
dioxxu's injuries the group is happy to
have killed so many people and decide to
kill more until they are the only ones
left so that they can take the prize
money migno sees that deoxy was favoring
the doctor more than her to become
closer to him she seductively invites
him to the washroom where the two have
intercourse inside a stall the following
morning everyone is woken up and told
that the third game will start
momentarily after a while they are taken
to an empty white room where they are
told to separate into a group of ten
people each gi yoon's team already has
five members so they decide to find one
person each dyoksu who already knows
what the game is asks his men to gather
some more well-built men migno is at a
loss for words when he tells her she
cannot be on the team she begs him to
let her in only to be shoved to the
ground meanwhile sabiak approaches a
girl who is sitting alone in a corner
she agrees to be in their team the
others bring one man each except for
enom so the group only has nine members
migno who has been kicked out of dioxius
group joins them at the last moment they
are then brought to a massive hall that
has a tall bridge in the front the third
game turns out to be tug of war the
players are supposed to pull a rope to
their side and the ones who lose will
fall from the tall bridge and die gi
yoon's team has two girls and an old man
so the chance of their winning is low
but the aksu has already gathered the
strongest men of the crowd their group
goes against another group the others
watch in nervousness as the first match
starts dioxin's team wins it almost
instantly and the other group hangs onto
the rope to eventually fall to the
ground below at last the staff take
their bodies away the next is gi yoon's
team they nervously get up knowing that
their chances are low moreover their
opponents are all men who seem to be
particularly strong however enom claims
that he used to be the best at tug of
war when he was a kid he briefs them on
some of the basic techniques of the game
first the one on the front has to be a
strong person who can communicate with
the others by tilting his head to the
sides and the last one has to be the
strongest secondly one player should be
at each side of the rope so the pole is
stronger third all their feet should be
facing forward and they should hold onto
the rope with their armpits as well the
final and most important thing is that
the team should hold their ground for
the first 10 seconds after the game
starts
that way you can take the opponent by
surprise when their rhythm starts to
break
using these techniques the group is
almost about to win but the opponents
pull the rope harder at the last moment
they are almost pulled to the edge when
seng wu comes up with a last minute plan
he asks everyone to loosen their hold
for some seconds so the opponents will
lose their balance the episode ends as
they let go of the rope on the count of
three
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching